you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up a litany of broken
climate promises a dire warning from the
un after the world scientists issued
their latest report on climate change it
is a file of shame
cataloging the empty pledges that put us
firmly on track towards an unbelievable
world
we are on a fast track to climate
disaster
but there is still a route to stopping
that disaster say scientists top of the
list stop burning fossil fuels
nature can help us too naturally soaking
up the world's carbon emissions while
improving quality of life
and heavy industry must decarbonize say
the scientists we look at one solution
which sweden wants to export to the
world
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
so today another stark warning from the
world's climate scientists the un's
intergovernmental panel on climate
change has issued its latest report
they say promises made by governments
and corporations are not being kept
carbon emissions keep rising and it's
nearly too late to hit the targets
necessary to limit global warming to 1.5
degrees and stop a climate disaster
the report says that the world's
greenhouse gas emissions must peak
before 2025
then reduced by 43 percent by 2030 and
reached net zero by 2050.
the report says that will require huge
changes across every sector but
crucially it is still possible the
energy sector must quickly reduce its
use of fossil fuels and move to
electrification and improved energy
efficiency
this low-carbon technology is advancing
fast and costs have fallen continuously
since 2010 the cost of solar has fallen
by 85 percent
wind power has fallen by 55 percent and
lithium-ion batteries used for storage
and transport are now 85
cheaper and these technologies are
rolling out fast
now industry accounts for about a
quarter of global emissions and
achieving net zero will be challenging
and require new production processes low
carbon electricity hydrogen and where
necessary carbon capture and storage
nature can provide some solutions
agriculture forestry and other land use
can provide large-scale emissions
reductions and can help remove and store
carbon dioxide at scale
our science correspondent thomas more
reports
climate change is now happening so fast
that leaving oil in the ground is no
longer enough
a new assessment by scientists working
for the united nations shows we need to
halve our greenhouse gas emissions in
just eight years
but we also need to find some way of
removing carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere to undo the damage of the
past we are on a fast track to climate
disaster
measures heat is underwater
unprecedented waves terrifying storms
widespread water shortages the
extinction of a million species of
plants and animals
and these is not fiction or exaggeration
it is what science tells us will result
from our current energy policies
nature can be our ally according to the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change steered marshes and somerset
cover just one square mile but they
remove and store almost 18 000 tons of
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere every
year scale that up plant trees stop peat
bogs being drained and rewilding could
buy us time
it can happen relatively quickly we know
how to do it
it takes time steep you know it took
eight years or so but in the grand
scheme of things that's that's not a
long time and if we unlock these sorts
of solutions at scale we can do this
within the next five to ten years and
buy ourselves that time to bring the
technologies on stream in the longer
term to reduce our emissions further
the first attempts are being made to use
technology to suck carbon dioxide out of
the air and store it underground it's
expensive and inefficient for now but
the un scientists say without it there
is little hope of raining in the rapid
rise in global temperatures
the glasgow climate conference was just
a small step in the right direction
pledges to cut emissions are not the
same as action and at the moment the
world is still on course for three
degrees of warming
the report is scathing about our
continued use of fossil fuels coal in
particular it calls for an even more
rapid shift to renewables more energy
efficient housing and a rethink of how
we design cities so people need to drive
less
one of the scientists says it can be
done
if we
act
now
if we act rapidly if we make the big
transformational changes that are
necessary
there's still a glimmer of hope of
getting to 1.5 and if we missed 1.5
we still stopped it going
1.6 1.7 1.8 so whatever effort we put in
will save lives
the report was delayed by two days as
195 governments wrangled over the text
the un chief has accused them of lying
over their past climate commitments and
scientists are clear on the urgent need
for action it's now or never
thomas more sky news
well the u.n secretary general antonio
guterres said today that investing in
new fossil fuels infrastructure is moral
and economic madness so how does that
match up with boris johnson's comments
he said the uk needs to exploit more of
its oil and gas because it faces a
crunch caused by the war in ukraine well
alex sharma is president of cop 26 and
hosted the un climate conference in
glasgow in november
well i if you if you look at what uh the
uk has set up we've said that um we will
be producing um a hundred percent of
electricity from uh clean energy sources
by 2035 and if you look at the
transition that we've had in our
electricity mix we've gone from 40
percent of of uh use of of coal in 2012
uh to less than sort of two two percent
right now and we've built the second
biggest offshore wind sector in the
world and what we've been very clear
about and we set this out actually back
at the end of 2020 as part of the prime
minister's plan for a green industrial
revolution
is to turbocharge an expansion of
renewables to invest in nuclear to
invest in hydrogen and that's what we've
been doing now in terms of oil and gas
we've always been very clear that what
we want to see is a managed transition
uh away from hydrocarbons uh but as in
fact the ibc's report which has come out
today and the iea zone report last year
set out that even in a
2015 net zero uh energy mix globally
there will still be some hydrocarbons as
part of that but can you rule out any
new investment in fossil fuels and in
north sea oil and gas production well
again you know we we set out very
clearly that we would be introducing a
climate compatibility checkpoint on
looking at any new licenses
and that would have to be uh those would
have to be consistent uh with our our
own climate commitments which is uh net
zero enshrined in law by 2050. there was
a consultation that took place and in
due course the business department will
set out the details of those checkpoints
can the uk reduce its reliance on fossil
fuels at a time like this when we're
committing to ending our dependence on
russian oil and gas and when we're
facing the worst cost of living crisis
since the 1950s largely because of
soaring energy prices
well and at first the uh it's worth
pointing out that actually we are not uh
dependent on um russian hydrocarbons
less than four percent of our gas comes
from from russian sources um but of
course what we are looking to do along
with many other countries to wean
ourselves off uh russian hydrocarbons
and the reason uh that we are in a far
better position than other countries is
because we have built uh one of the
biggest offshore wind sectors in the
world we've invested in new renewables
and we're going to be doing a lot more
of that
in terms of how you ensure
domestic security of energy supply and
you have control over prices is to
ensure that you have homegrown clean
energy and i think what you're going to
see is an acceleration of that across
many countries where they've understood
that that is how you ensure security
supply
well joining me now is co barrett she's
a vice chair of the ipcc and has served
as a lead negotiator for the us on the
un treaty on climate change so welcome
to you thanks for joining us
the un secretary general today has said
that we're on a fast track to a climate
disaster so what's your conclusion is it
possible to prevent that disaster and is
there the political will
well anna thank you so much for having
me and for showing some interest in our
important report in fact all of the
reports from this cycle
uh yeah i heard the on uh the un
secretary general's comments and you
know i think he's he's right we are
really in quite a challenging situation
here we have to make immediate and deep
cuts um if we have any chance of holding
temperature to 1.5 degrees
but the thing about this report that i'd
like to stress is that it is also full
of solutions uh solutions that
individuals can take in their own lives
at their commun at the community level
and of course putting pressure on
governments to make the big
transformational changes that are needed
so what are the solutions because the
task is a big one i mean the report sets
out that we need to cut emissions nearly
in half in just eight years so how do
you do it clearly and the energy sector
is a place where we can make some major
changes right renewable energies shift
to renewables has been a tremendous
opportunity already and we can only do
more there um but also i would say
two-thirds of emissions
are related to cities or the services
that are provided in cities
and that's a tremendous opportunity for
us to make change because it's a scale
at which individual action actually has
impact people can see the changes that
they make in their communities and in
cities it gives us a chance to kind of
work together with our neighbors to work
in the places that we really care about
and to make some significant action
you talk about the shift to renewables
but the war in ukraine has forced many
countries to to rethink their energy
supply haven't they because it's become
an issue of national security at a time
of already soaring energy prices so many
people feel they have no alternative but
to produce more fossil fuels at a time
like this what would you say to them
yeah it's true i mean that is a very
ripe discussion going on right now but i
would just say you know the near term is
not the um the only way to look at this
uh the solutions to this problem we know
we have to shift to renewables and away
from fossil fuels
and uh while we deal with crises in
different ways in the near term the
long-term solutions are also really
powerful and important
and a quick word on technology to remove
carbon from the air
the report says it's needed but is there
a risk that sends out the message that
technology can fix this problem
you know i've heard that argument anna
and um i actually think that that is not
as relevant as people try to make it
seem
yes it's true we cannot take off any
pressure from the mainstream solution to
this problem which is reducing
greenhouse gas emissions
but
reducing emissions and pulling them from
the air through carbon dioxide removal
is a part of the solution and it's also
a way that we can do that in conjunction
with reducing greenhouse gas emissions
let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and climate campaigners
extinction rebellion staged a protest at
an oil facility near heathrow airport
the group blocked the entrance with
bamboo structures and banners that urge
the government to stop using fossil
fuels this is the fourth day of action
by extinction rebellion and a second
campaign group just stop oil who say
they'll continue to protest every day
until the government stops fossil fuel
investments
mps have urged the government to set up
a carbon border to prevent net zero
emissions targets being undermined by
cheap foreign imports the environmental
audit committee said the introduction of
a carbon border adjustment mechanism
pricing imports according to their
carbon output would be a powerful lever
to bring down overall emissions
at present goods produced in the uk
already have a carbon pricing system
while imports which account for more
than 40 percent of goods consumed are
not covered
and scientists have found that by the
end of this century the chance of an
extreme rainfall event in california
happening within a year of wildfires
will double and researchers say
increased wildfires across the western
u.s will be more likely to result in
serious flooding that's because recently
burned areas have a higher risk of
mudslides and flash floods as the soil
and vegetation can't absorb as much rain
or provide as much cover
now for hundreds of years raging blast
furnaces fed with heavily polluting
coking coal have forged the steel used
to build the modern world but the
process is a huge source of carbon
dioxide emissions one solution is to use
green hydrogen now that's hydrogen
produced without emissions to replace
the coal one project in sweden is making
progress and hopes to export their
technology to the world
[Music]
instead of using coal we want to use
hydrogen and hydrogen can do the same
work to reduce i know we get iron for c
production as a by-product we get water
we present and that can be recycled
[Music]
we are still the largest filtering
meeting company in both sweden and
finland
we stand for 10 percent of c2 mission in
sweden and 7
in finland
teal will be in the harder to abate
sectors to decarbonize it will take more
time green steel that is produced by an
ssab or by other producers
is at least 50 percent more expensive
than the high carbon steel at this point
in time but the technology that has been
tested by ssap now at an initial scale
is very exciting
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by julia king who's on the committee on
climate change and chaitanya kumar head
of green transition at the new economics
foundation and we'll be discussing that
crucial ipcc report how realistic is it
now that the world can stop global
warming and what can you do to help
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm sky's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind power
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm confident for the last 30 years we
have known how bad it is i'm not here to
apologize i'm here to fight for the next
step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these this sofas and people's
desks and children's books and you can
see inside this home here people trying
to uh
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of the beauty
around us the future
of you and me
the ukrainian government is confirming
that they are now engaged with russia's
soldiers
air raid sirens fill the airways in the
distance artillery rains down it feels
very close to the center oh
there's one they found this devastation
to their apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
committee on climate change member dane
julia king and head of green transition
at the new economics foundation
chaitanya kumar so welcome to both of
you good to see you both
so this ipcc report is a litany of
broken climate promises and investment
in new fossil fuels infrastructure is
moral and economic madness so says the
u.n secretary general antonio gutierrez
that's a searing indictment so just how
important is this report out today
julie king to you first of all what do
you make of the report and its
significance what does it tell us about
our ability to limit the worst impacts
of climate change
well i think it gives us some very
important messages
one of them that i took away is that we
need to see three to six times more
financial investment in green solutions
so really we can't afford to be
investing more in fossil fuels
it's crucial that we're directing that
investment to green solutions
the other the other very strong message
i think that comes through from it is
urgency we've got three years to get to
turn the increase in emissions the
annual increases in emissions we're
seeing um to stop that and to get those
emissions declining by 2025
we've got to stop increasing global
emissions that's a very short time so
it's positive that we can do it but we
really need to focus the finance and we
really need to speed up well yes and on
that timing issue titania what do you
make of that because they're saying we
need to cut emissions
by nearly half in just eight years 43 i
think it is i mean is that really doable
given that at the moment
globally pledges mean that emissions are
still going up by about 14 in that time
frame i mean it is difficult there's no
two ways about it it's quite a feat to
pull off a 40 reduction in eight years
time but that's what we have to do
that's the challenge that scientists
have been banging on about for several
years now
we've run out of excuses we've run out
of reasons for an action and we just
have to cut carbon as quickly and as
dramatically as we can
um peaking of emissions allows us some
headroom because we are factoring in you
know the pent up demand from the
pandemic emissions have gone up last
year they might even go up this year but
essentially we've got another three
years where we have to stop increasing
the amount of carbon we put in the
atmosphere every year
and the context is very important
because
every year we put more carbon into the
atmosphere which is worsening the
climate crisis and the impacts that come
along with it you know your report
earlier was talking about extreme heat
flooding wildfires all of these are
increasing in severity and intensity
and frequency and they're affecting the
people that are contributing the least
to the problem i think that's a key
thing that the report also talks about
where the contribution uh to the problem
and and those who pay for it in terms of
lives and livelihoods are different sets
of people and it really bears a point
about responsibility and who owns
responsibility here and developed
countries uh clearly all responsibility
in terms of financing the transition for
a lot of the countries in the global
cell okay but also ensuring that we
model the transition here
julia tania says there that we're
running out of excuses and yet some
would say the war in ukraine
has put new pressures on people the the
soaring energy prices has put new
pressures on countries some of them are
having to turn to fossil fuels i mean
there are short-term problems that
countries are wrestling with aren't
there
but but surely the the best solution to
soaring energy prices is increasing
energy efficiency um using less energy
which is something you know which is
going to be fundamental to our um
our transition so this is the
opportunity to be supporting energy
efficiency to make sure people
understand what they can do to reduce
their energy use
well that's really interesting how much
will this come down chaitanya to
individuals and them changing behavior
in future because i think this is the
first time the report does have chapters
on reducing demand are we going to face
a very different futures and how we as
individuals use our energy do you think
most certainly there's no doubt about it
i think
it's a mix of individual action but it
shouldn't be a substitute for collective
action for government action but when it
comes to individuals i'd say there are
three things that we all could be doing
the first thing of course is cutting our
own fossil fuel consumption so as julia
was saying insulating our homes making
our homes more energy efficient is the
first and and the most obvious to me
where we can cut our carbon uh emissions
the second i'd say is reducing how we uh
how we travel in terms of fossil fuel
based uh carbon intensive waste so
reducing air travel for example is
another way of doing it and the third of
course is
really moving on to more healthier diets
that is away from industrial based meat
production if you did that then i think
our personal carbon footprint could be
reduced quite quickly and when you add
it all up it really makes a difference
at the global level so so julie this
implies pressure is not just on
government and policy but also on
individuals i mean that's going to be
quite hard isn't it quite a hard sell to
get people to change their behaviors and
give up freedoms
i think most people are worried about
what kind of world we're going to live
we're going to leave to our children and
our grandchildren um you know this is uh
this is something that that we know
every survey shows us in the uk that
people are really concerned about and of
course last year we saw some really
really extreme weather and some really
serious consequences um you know as as
close as germany um large numbers of
people killed in flooding so i think
people recognize that we have to act on
this
and i think actually the the fuel crisis
um just is is just the prompt we need uh
to recognize that that taking action
like um energy efficiency is something
we have to do now and of course we saw a
huge surge in cycling at the start of
the pandemic when the roads were clear
unfortunately that's now disappeared
again but you know we all need to get
back on our bikes and and walking and
in my case uh getting rid of those extra
pounds we piled on during the lockdown
and briefly at chaitanya the the world
scientists
climate scientists have agreed that 1.5
degrees of global warming is the kind of
limit that's tolerable in in terms of
the future of our planet are we on track
for it do you think well one of the lead
authors uh in the press release came out
and said uh we've all but locked in the
1.5 limit as we're going to breach the
1.5 target but we can pull it back um
and it genuinely requires rapid
collective action around the world so
the the set of solutions the suite of
options we've got in front of us they're
a lot um
but the window of opportunity the window
of time is is closing down
okay well chaitanya kumar julia king
good to see you but thanks very much
indeed for your reaction to the ipcc
report we appreciate it
thank you
well that's all for today but joining me
on the show tomorrow our chief executive
of climate group helen clarkson an
environmental activist and columnist of
the guardian george monbio thanks for
watching